hablamos ahora de economía en directo
américa me acompaña en el estudio jorge
hurtado jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos hablando de la economía de
eeuu entra o no entra en recesión es un
debate que se está dando tanto allí como
en el mundo entero santiago y es que
luego de conocerse esta semana la
contracción del 0,9 por ciento del
producto interno bruto en el segundo
trimestre frente al mismo trimestre del
año pasado
la teoría dicta que es economía entró en
recesión técnica pero la casa blanca la
reserva federal y el tesoro de ese país
argumentan que hay otros factores en la
economía para negar esa recesión para
jorge suárez vélez economista y
columnista del diario reforma para saber
si en realidad existe una recesión ahora
tendremos que esperar porque este es un
indicador que llega con algo de retraso
escuchamos
en una definición que es bastante
estrecha digamos que dice que si acumula
dos trimestres consecutivos de
crecimiento negativo eso es una
restricción la mayoría de las entidades
respetables no están recordar esa
definición lo que ellos dicen es que una
restricción es cuando tienes una
desaceleración generalizada en toda la
economía durante un periodo
razonablemente largo de tiempo y hay dos
desventajas tenemos la primera es que
usualmente no sabemos que ven la
recesión hasta que ya la hubo es decir
todos los indicadores que vas a tener de
crecimiento son indicadores están
retrasados si mides el trimestre pasado
en muchas ocasiones te vas a dar cuenta
de que hubo una recesión cuando ya
además de salido cuando ya esté ya ya
pasó lo mismo pasa de hecho con esta
medición que estamos viendo de un
segundo trimestre de crecimiento
negativo
porque hay revisiones que se hacen
después de esta primera toma entonces es
posible que todas las revisiones que
vienen pudiera pudieran decir que de
hecho no hubo una contracción sino que
hubo un ligero
jorge independiente de las cifras lo que
sí hay es un sentimiento pesimista en el
ambiente no solo en eeuu también en
américa latina' de hecho una encuesta
que realiza bloomberg entre economistas
revela que existe la probabilidad de
recesión para los próximos 12 meses en
un 50 o casi 50 por ciento y eso es la
cifra más alta en los últimos años sobre
todo cuando la inflación anual supere el
9 por ciento en los hogares el
sentimiento puede jugar un papel
psicológico importante y según los
analistas el peligro más allá de la
discusión técnica sobre qué es una
recesión es que se genera una especie de
efecto contagio entre las economías
también hay que prestar mucha atención a
china nos dice nuestro invitado
yo creo que la realidad hacer que china
probablemente va a estabilizar su
crecimiento así finales de esta década
en tasas de entre 2 y 3 por ciento
porque esto es relevante porque si vemos
el periodo entre 2013 y 2018 china fue
el 28 por ciento el crecimiento del
mundo es decir se está pagando uno de
los grandes motores de crecimiento del
mundo y ahora le tendremos mucho más por
ejemplo de que haga eeuu pues yo creo
que el tema para
y para otros regiones es que viene un
entorno de menor crecimiento y en este
entorno de menor crecimiento aparte
vemos que están haciendo cosas que
ayudarán a que haya menos crecimiento en
todo este proteccionismo que empieza a
surgir todo esta regionalización de
cadenas de suministro todo esta ataque
digamos a la globalización
esta contracción o intentos de contraer
el comercio internacional
algo que provocó mucho crecimiento el
principio de este siglo fue el
crecimiento en el comercio entonces
ahora podríamos tener el efecto
contrario es decir creo que en cualquier
forma que lo veamos viene un entorno de
menos crecimiento que que puede tener
cierta complicación hacia lo político
también jorge y todo este escenario cómo
puede impactar las economías de américa
latina bueno de hecho ya los mercados
buscan alejarse las inversiones de
riesgo se han disminuido los contratos a
futuro de las materias primas el fuerte
de américa latina- por supuesto mientras
el dólar toma fuerza arrastrando monedas
locales y también mucho de los países en
la región tienen su deuda en dólares y
con las tasas de interés más altas los
pagos de esos intereses de deuda
aumentan otro factor es que los
capitales migran hacia estados unidos en
busca de mejores beneficios y se podría
desacelerar las exportaciones de los
países latinoamericanos hacia esa nación
le preguntamos a jorge suárez si cuando
habría una recesión y esto nos respondió
y todo apuntaría a que es posible que
llegáramos a esta quizá a principios del
año que viene
y
pero hay otros economistas ya nery hablé
de entre ellos que dicen que puede sigue
siendo posible que haya esto lo que le
denominan un aterrizaje suave es decir
que logres quitar de encima esta presión
inflacionaria sin necesariamente tener
que
frenar tanto la economía que entres en
una recesión muchas gracias jorge es
todo por el momento aquí en la economía
en directo américa a continuación el
debate